c'est une visite qui symbolise ce
rapprochement entre le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite venir de doha est
chaleureusement accueilli par le prince
héritier saoudien mohamed ben salman à
el oula tamim al-thani participe à son
premier sommet du conseil de coopération
du golfe depuis juin 2010 cette date à
laquelle l'arabie saoudite les émirats
bahreïn et l'egypte ont rompu leurs
relations diplomatiques avec doit en
cause notamment son soutien supposé à
des groupes djihadistes ainsi qu'une
trop grande proximité avec l'iran
sous les yeux de jared kushner gendrey
conseiller du président américain
sortant mohamed ben salman annonce la
signature d'un accord de solidarité et
de stabilité
les efforts du coa et et des états unis
nous ont aidés à obtenir un accord où
nous affirmons notre solidarité et la
stabilité du golfe et des pays arabes et
musulmans et réajustant les relations
amicales entre nos pays afin de servir
les intérêts de nos peuples
conséquence concrète de cet accord le
rétablissement total des relations entre
le qatar et les quatre pays qui de
boycotter l'arabie saoudite bahreïn
l'egypte et les émirats vont ainsi
rouvrir leurs frontières terrestres
aériennes et maritimes au qatari qui
pourront les franchir librement
il a été décidé aujourd'hui grâce à la
sagesse des dirigeants du golfe et de
l'egypte de tourner la page et de
rétablir toutes les relations
diplomatiques avec le qatar ainsi que
tout ce qui sert les relations entre les
pays membres du conseil de coopération
de l'egypte nous espérons que ce sera
une étape importante vers l'avenir et la
stabilité de la région
reste désormais à savoir si cette
réconciliation pourra durer les quatre
pays avaient formulé 13 condition à la
reprise des relations avec le qatar
notamment la fermeture de la chaîne al
jazeera ou des engagements sur la fin du
financement supposé de groupes
extrémistes doha ne s'est plié à aucune
de ces exigences